the ray value were headed into a period
like the 1970s so by inflation hedge
assets
uh farmed hedge fund a famed hedge fund
manager ray dalio said on tuesday he
thinks that the global economy is headed
into a period like 1970s dominated by
inflation concerns on potential
stagnation
as a result he said investors should
focus on inflation hedge assets as a way
to protect their portfolio during the
coming turbulent times for financial
markets value express skepticism about
the federal reserve's ability to tamp
down inflation without triggering a
recession he argued that too much debt
has been
created in a short period of time for
the central bank to offset without
massively increasing interest rates
uh even himself is saying these times
are coming and he's not even holding
back
how bad are things going to be tom the
next 12 to 18 months i think they're
going to get really really rough because
i think that we could be potentially
getting into a time like the full decade
where the japanese economy had to
recover because our monetary policy you
know yes it was about coved yes it was
about getting relief checks to people
but you have to remember the second
trillion that went out there was over a
10-year period correct it was flowed out
and so it basically becomes a slush fund
for congress for 10 years and so
basically that is irresponsible monetary
policy when you take a look at what was
printed you take a look at the debt he's
right what all he's saying is
the economy just ate these things
it has to digest it and there's and
it's going to be indigestion and it's
going to be inflation and they're not
going to be able to tamp it down he's
correct on an absolutely fundamental
level and what what is the alternative
right now
what is slowing down the housing market
interest rates right
so what do you do do you move the
interest rates back to zero
i think he's right you cannot do that
you can't do that no you got to feel the
pain so that's what i'm saying you ate
some bad beef and you gotta go through
the food poisoning and it's going to
take time to get it through the system
sorry to use that visual apologize but i
think we're looking at the ten years
up to ten years just like the japanese
economy had i don't know what if you
look back 80s 90s you know he said
something that really stuck out to me he
said we're in a time where ideologies
and politics drive economics not the
other way around and i think obviously
there's it's a complex issue with the
fed and monetary policy and decades of
of things gone awry but i also the the
political part is very important and why
we need members of congress who are
pro-growth and who understand economics
because ultimately it's the american
people are the ones who are going to
suffer when you have politicians that
want to increase minimum wages
when you have again coveted lockdowns
and some blue states unconstitutional
lockdowns where you're destroying small
businesses all of that stuff really does
matter and it is supply chain issues all
of this was incredibly political and so
when you have this kind of perfect storm
of things you need people who are able
to ring to bring it back
and ultimately again these kitchen table
issues what what americans when i'm on
the campaign trail they're worried about
going to a restaurant and things are 50
percent marked up and then the
restaurant owner all the food all they
have to raise their prices
uh groceries groceries are getting more
expensive gas is getting more expensive
it has become so political and ray dalio
was so on point when he said that that
the economy is now being driven by
ideology and politics and way it never
happened i don't disagree folks if you
want to find out like how
how and what gas prices are affecting
go go price out the flight that you
usually take and write down the number
that you pay for the flight that you
usually take whatever flight it may be
maybe la2 dallas okay maybe new york to
miami whatever it is that you usually go
on and use american airlines or you know
jetblue or some of you guys who are
extremely courageous spirit or whatever
whatever you take right
and then go price it out today and see
what the number is today go go look at
what happened today it it affects so
many different industries by the way
this article continues with another
article that has to do with this one fox
business u.s economy on the cusp of
stack flash and world's largest hedge
fund warrants this is a completely
different person
uh bridgewater associate chief
investment officer bob prince said this
week that markets have not fully
absorbed the shock of what's happening
in the economy and investors are too
optimistic about the path for inflation
and interest rates and stagflation is
the combination of economy
stagnation and high inflation
characterized by soaring consumer prices
as well as high unemployment the
phenomenon
ravaged the u.s economy in the 70s and
80s as a spike in oil prices rising
unemployment and high monetary policy
pushed the consumer price index as high
as 14.8 percent in 1980 forcing fed
policymaker to raise interest rates to
nearly you ready 20 percent and by the
way
to the experts who don't think that's
possible
they are unbelievably naive because
never in the history the company have we
printed money like we have right now
expect expect interest rates to go to
that level let me give two tips i got i
want to read one other article here that
talks about if you were the person that
were too loyal to your company you
didn't go get another raise at another
job you made a mistake that's a business
insider solely we'll read that but i
want to give you a tip
if you're thinking about buying a house
this is purely my opinion you don't have
to take it but i'm just giving it to you
if you're thinking about buying a house
and you're so excited about buying a
house
if
if you can wait 12 to 18 months do so
if you are so excited about buying a
house
that you're just like oh my god but i
love this place if you can somehow
set aside your emotional love for that
new house for 12 or 18 months you're
going to win here's why
the mortgage payment is not gonna be
different you're still going to pay the
same payment you're paying today for
that house because you buy the same
house 18 months from now that's probably
a million dollar house today you'll pay
720 for it
but interest rates are going to be eight
and a half percent so your payment's
going to be the same
but
that one million that one million dollar
house that becomes 720 it's going to go
back to him in a million dollar house
seven years from now five years from now
except you kept at 280 and then you'll
refinance when interest rates come down
5-10 years from now and you pay lower
payment so if you can emotionally
prevent yourself from jumping on the
house that you want to buy right now
wait 12 to 18 more months it's probably
going to be a wise move on your end now
people who are not going to like me
saying this are loan officers and
realtors realtors and loan officers i
love you
i support you on what you do
your job is to convince them that i'm
wrong i'm totally okay with that that's
how debates and arguments happen but i'm
telling you
i think i'm right it's okay when it
comes down to this idea with house but
do you think tom do you think it has a
likelihood of getting as crazy as it was
in the 70s and 80s of
14 type of things like do you think it
can get to a number like that i i think
it has
all the raw materials in here the
kindling is here that the fire could
burn that hot but i don't think it will
you know i think there's a lot more
controls and things that banks are going
to be put in place by the way don't
forget to leave out wells fargo the
largest issue or mortgages united states
that's upset with you right now but um
well let me ask you a question because
if ray dalio is right by the way your
property tax also goes down your
property taxes when you buy that house
that's a very meaningful part of home
ownership it could be a thousand bucks a
month your property taxes are probably
now down to 750 600 yeah your insurance
rates are going to go up that's a big
problem that's going on here in miami is
that all the
property uh insurance rates are
skyrocketing but here's my question for
you because that won't change though
that's not going to change no matter
what well not according to miami herald
i mean whatever we don't need to get
into the article right here but
apparently the
insurance rates have skyrocketed thirty
percent because of what though
you want me to read the article what i'm
trying to say it's gonna go up no matter
what though
it's not going down because of whatever
the current times are you're gonna pay
that a year from now
whether you like it or not that that
that fee is not going away but go ahead
make it yeah no no i mean i don't want
to uh pull out the article right now so
if if if real estate's going down stock
market's going down crypto's going down
ray dalio's basically saying so buy
inflate inflation hedge assets and i
don't know if you were using a freudian
slip right there so here's some tips for
you are you saying what should you
invest in tips treasury inflation uh
protected securities something like that
where should people be putting their
money you gave a great speech at the the
think conference what was it called grow
live with video grow grow live with
video shows great speech it was awesome
and you said hey this is a great time
where you can add an extra zero to your
net worth over the next few years
other than making more money right you
know and choosing your uh income
producing uh
mentality better
where should people be putting their
money now if if real estate is going
down stock market's going down crypto's
going down depending where should you be
the average person or the person that
wants to really play ball and ask
average person the average person needs
to
uh
if you're if you're in equities equities
is going to take a hit it's just it is
going to take a hit so but i don't want
to give that advice because too many
times when they say that
then they forget to go back in equities
when the momentum is back up and they
take a big hit for it so if you're not
somebody that's watching your stuff let
your advisor give the advice i don't
know what situation you're in uh but i
will tell you right now if there's ever
been a perfect time to add that
additional zero to your net worth
today's the time the next two to five
years a lot of things are going to be on
sale a lot of things are going to be on
sale people so you're saying stack cash
even though even though inflation is at
eight percent whatever i think
opportunities are gonna go to the roof
the next 12 to 18 months ask why a
buffett that knows more about money than
99.99999 percent of the world why is he
sitting on so much cash right now maybe
because he knows how much things are
going to be on sale and he's going to
pick up things on sale it's just the
reality of it so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]
you